we shouldn't ban people from eating
burgers or make them ungodly expensive
you're living in the world of what-if
with climate change well you're anti
science hold on a second do you believe
that if someone is born a man but he
cuts off as that he's a woman now it's
just hate science
Democrats and Republicans as it relates
to government regulation or everyday
life rate it ranges from banning vaping
to no more red meat this is what we're
gonna talk about today what's the most
ridiculous proposed regulation that
you've heard of in the past few weeks
and do you think that right now
Republicans Democrats are two sides of
the same coin
I think we're kind of there but let's
move on to the topic at hand lest you
need a new reason to disdain veganism
and CNN there's a recent did you see the
climate Town Hall yeah they're doing an
LGBTQ Town Hall what for LGBT issues Oh
that'll be fun what you're already
confusing to women's mix martial arts
number one and two track and field stars
are men computers winning sports huh
like what else do you you can you can
take a dump anywhere you want
practically and you don't have to go
into a restaurant you want no one's
gonna say anything you're privileged
wouldn't what more you get me I mean
marriage is way down the list because
that's a lot what issues alright anyway
so we have to go back climb at Town Hall
yeah the debates of course it's
recovered for people who missed the
stream Democrats have been presenting a
laundry list of things they want to stop
Americans from doing to save the
environment
and among these is eating it's not just
the DNC by the way you've been hearing
this for a long time you know the UN
just released a study that said we're
gonna be okay
if the vast majority of the world goes
vegetarian immediately from using a
straw in a certain way yes are we did a
paired to deal with the health and
environmental consequences of
maintaining current levels definitely
read as a meat and gifts kind of
consumption some of it is with light
bulbs some of it is on straws some of it
dang is on cheeseburgers right it has no
polluting it's the number one Aryan
contributors one day we one day without
eating animal people who look like me
how huge
but in helping maintain the delicate
poets join us join us join us we free on
Mondays these are the two broads in
there is like they put in the lines I
read is one of them do you I can't pick
her we need someone to fill this out
because it's a little too white nation
even though you know it's the the single
highest grossing women take the second
ad just toss her in there I think she
was in Good Wife do I need any makeup no
you're next to Paul McCartney no one's
gonna notice
so obviously the main point years
they're all hypocrites you still like
but that doesn't make an argument so
hold your nose here comes the cold water
veganism this is something you don't
hear a lot is potentially much worse for
the planet no let me cycle through this
reason one sustainability let me talk
about this with a leer Keith a long time
ago topsoil erosion yeah so uh do we say
omnivorous that omnivorous
I'm never see I'm never I'm never as
farming is actually a lot more
sustainable than the vegan model so
globally we have 21 make sure I get this
right 25 to 40 billion tons of topsoil
are lost every year to erosion mainly
due to plowing intense cropping yeah in
the UK the top soil depletion is so bad
that the farmers think they may actually
never be able to harvest that land at
all again Wow and how do you combat this
this is something people you won't hear
from Paul McCartney in ad number one and
right one of them was a photographer
really had an Instagram model had a
local boat
we need her in that show a local book
when she does the twerk so the way to
combat this the top seller is just
letting the land just letting it return
to being great it asks you for a period
and that results in complete halting of
the erosion and it rebuilds a soil
basically what you need to do is leave
it for the animals and then we I think
that's a that's a very good system by
the way why are they just now learning
of what we learned in the Dust Bowl yeah
like we figured this out a heck of a
long time ago why is this coming back up
yeah you will not read they don't know
they absolutely don't yeah I just wanted
to remain sound so you got answers are
less sustainable by the way then
neveress diets in the long term collage
for you and before we move on to other
reasons hit the notification bell join
up at Mudd Club ladder that comes to us
Michael if you have not already you get
access to the full daily show which
you're not showing here on YouTube
yeah we just can't because it'll mostly
get bad so another reason that Mugen is
it might be worse for the environment
people don't think about this it's often
overlooked the importation of food now
here's what some people don't realize
the guns are not advocating and apples
only if you live in the Northeast diet
while thrid Ian's and Californians enjoy
the corn you cope you have a year-round
growing season keep this in mind too
when we talk about if your
great-grandmother didn't need it you
should well your great-grandmother was
lucky to get an orange in her stocking
and if your great-great grandfather was
a dick he would give your
great-grandmother coal and her stockings
because he wanted a discipline her and
give her the fear of God and ruins the
magic of Santa so the point is they
didn't get to a very diet
no so then we understand where I'm going
with this yes yes the points they want a
very diet and it requires a lot of food
like quinoa avocados they be imported
often from countries that don't have the
same regulations or sustainable form
right so regulations that you have in
Grand Rapids Michigan it's similar to
when they talk about we want to shut
down fracking we want to shut down this
pepper we want to stop us from having
access to our own oil reserves in Alaska
okay I understand that you don't like
using energy right I don't like well
just like you don't like eating animals
that being said people in the world are
eating animals so yeah you got to set
how they kill those animals that being
said people in the world are growing
vegetables you don't have control over
how they grow them in Mexico when we
talk about oil you don't have control
over what they do in Saudi Arabia or in
these places in the Middle East that I
think sometimes I feel like we should
just make look like Cal ELLs Bachelor
Pad
nice-lookin I think you're right well
redo fracking here we have an EPA said
no let's just not do that what we're
still driving cars and so we're
different from other place yeah it ends
up being just as bad but they're taking
you're kind of you're right to choose in
the process right you're right to choose
kind of what products and services that
you want to be able to use right right
and by mandating you have to do
something like this no it's better for
the economy and I think we're gonna get
to a point by the way it's a you know
one of the interesting things is so so
what we're saying is that it's more
there's a moral imperative to no longer
eat fish there's a moral and Raritan not
eat meat because of the harm it causes
to the environment and to the animals
themselves keflex but we're not ever
gonna consider the millions of animals
that are killed when there's widespread
I mean there's like when you kill these
fields you you'd have to destroy natural
habitat oh dear my number one reason but
we will get to that I have fast
underground it's actually worse than
your Goethe's do it but we're talking
about this it's so bad now that
countries like Mexico Kenya they've
completely depleted their supply of
certain foods and this is exactly why we
need to build a wall stop this the
avocados I cannot that was just Tom
Selleck did you know Tom Selleck I'm
stealing water in California when they
weren't yeah he was stealing water for
mikado farm and he hates avocados how
badass make until you saw a market
opportunity even though magnum p.i
doesn't like the taste all right
smoke that Rosie O'Donnell what do you
think is better for the environment
eating venison from a deer you bagged
yourself or eating meat from your local
yak farm for all I know fixing yourself
$20 toast with avocados that were grown
in Mexican tap water and tossed in the
trucks that travel 2,500 miles that's
not even the question at that point come
on what is a question for some folks
that's why three carbon emissions a lot
of people don't consider that farming
land for crops releases more carbon from
their soil than the land left for
grazing not considered the reality of
the alternatives that they suggest
absolutely in every single time they do
they do with taxes the economy with
socialism and every white this shouldn't
be any different then they don't just
don't think about it at all but we
talked about this last week the cotton
bags organic cotton
he'd have to use that cotton bag 20,000
times to break even the bust of a
plastic bag environment that means that
if you went grocery shop on for over
about three hundred and eighty years we
did the math so reason another reason
that number is horrible this is
something you were just um up the
animals actually killed Tecton to create
these crop yields yeah it's the thing a
lot of vegans may not realize this do
you know how its twenty especially
certain grains like wheat yeah I don't
know if it's corn I think we have a
source results in 25 times more scenting
animals I don't killed per kilogram of
usable protein there's more
environmental damage there's more animal
cruelty than farming red meat and I know
and I know what you're thinking you're
saying well you talking about grains we
could solve that problem if we go vegan
and gluten grain-free yeah but that's
that's just too gay that's where that's
a prison I'm not willing to cross
unsustainable
I really thought when you said we could
solve this problem you were just gonna
kill the vegans I thought that that I
was well there are some people who are
experimenting with Canada too far that's
action I mean I think that's a natural
progression there right if you're not
willing to eat animals you're willing to
eat things that are less than the
animals which merely Peterman's are less
important okay I feel like we're putting
words in their mouth at this point I
don't think okay I think you like kale
and hydroponics in Australia by the
billions of animals deliberately killed
every year deliberately this is just to
protect fruit vegetable crops yet human
consumption a lot people don't
understand a lot of people don't even
think about this this is verifiable yeah
and I get it that you're saying well
they're not as cute as a cow and they're
small because you know yeah screw the
city mouse who went out to the country
he was an adept Oh
oh my gosh in Napa Valley like they
actually have laws that say you can't
kill animals that are trying to eat your
grapes and by the way these are not like
concord grapes like table grapes they're
very expensive when you do the math yeah
it's like the grand owl setting up shop
in Florida next thing you know you have
some yellow hazard tape and you can't
put in your own pool you're done you've
got to change the pole shape to a little
kidney bean-shaped pool so you have room
cut out for the ground owl which is a
bird with the gift of flight that loses
Newark - please let's have it ground I
will cook out what would we be missing
without them I don't understand and none
of this is to say that we can't be
smarter the mob and our approach or the
compromises and you know I don't know
I've seen these commercials for insect
protein on podcast but this Joe Rogan oh
okay here's a good like goats use far
less land than cattle is that something
that's just kind of a cultural deal we
don't use goats as there are little
solutions like this gap um I do think so
this is important to note when you look
at the Town Hall and how long was it
seven hours the climate change Town Hall
and you look come on often I'm talking
about it it's that these this neo
environmentalism and vegans it's it's
not that it's Pro animal we all love
animals it's anti human yeah and by the
way this is a these are the same people
a lot of people understand this these
are the same people who lobbied and
created
trans-fat epidemic in this country so
for example McDonald's they used to use
tallow for fries after lobbying from
vegetarians the USDA they switched to
hydrogenated vegetable oils because it
was healthier right a lot of people it
started off with the agenda though if
they wanted to get more Americans on a
vegetarian diet the same thing for the
vilification of eggs dietary cholesterol
saturated fat a lot of people want to
act like was just General Mills right it
was their fault or was the Kellogg's but
the reason a lot of information firm
ation regarding dietary cholesterol in
the saturated fat was because of the
vegetarian Lobby and their agenda above
truth and they're doing the same thing
now is instead of what really bothers me
is when they say that Republicans are
anti science because we say hold on a
second wait wait a second we shouldn't
ban people from eating burgers or make
them ungodly expensive because of
something you believe you're living in
the world of what if with climate change
well you're anti science hold on a
second do you believe that if someone is
born a man but he cuts off as that he's
a woman now it's just hate science while
the burqa in the rule book what happened
to science when we're talking about
carbon emissions here right now instead
of claiming that they're dogmatic diet
is better for you which is what we saw
with vegetarians in the 60s and 70s they
are now playing the same misleading
angle on the American public by trying
to convince them to take this diet up
not because it's better for you but
because it's better for the planet well
guess what we found out that it wasn't
necessarily better for you and we now
know that it is very less likely worse
for the planet a video subscriber hit
the notification bell I think you see
some videos playing in boxes up above
but you may or may not know we've been
demonetized on YouTube so you can
actually support this channel by joining
mug club lot of credit calm slash mug
Club you get this wonderful handouts mug
along with hours of content every week
the full daily show that you don't get
here on YouTube also if you want to see
this with the hemp if you want to see
nip that can't be on YouTube you got to
join mug club
nips for bug Club